[Music]
all right
looks like we're good to go so tonight's
lecture is going to be over the ponziani
opening i know we've covered a couple
lines on our youtube before
with harrison kaiser so just want to
shout that out but tonight we're going
to be looking at
more of the main lines no weird tricky
gambits
other than the gambit that gave this
opening its name all right let's get
into it
um first move pawn e4 and pawn
e5 uh after pawn e5 we get knight to f3
which is just
developing our piece and adding pressure
to the center and black
must respond black's most common move
here is knight to c6
defending the pawn with a piece so so
you're developing as well
and now we get this move pawn to c3
which indicates the ponziani opening
now this opening has been recorded as
early as 1497
and early in its career this opening was
known as staunton's
opening after howard staunton uh
so here after c3 what are the main ideas
uh well i think i'll actually ask the
chat what do you guys think are the main
ideas here i see a couple questions
coming in that uh
we can answer while i wait for you guys
responses
okay uh we have a question is this
opening good for kids or beginners
i i don't really think i can recommend
it for the
the brand new chess players some of the
ideas here are a bit
more strategic rather than just
completely tactical
which kids seem to excel at
you probably want to have a little bit
of chess experience under
your belt here
so yeah with that being said ross berry
i don't think it would be a good first
opening okay we have some of the ideas
coming through here
dot spider is saying the idea is pawn to
d4
sandro shock is saying pawn to b4 with a
delayed evans gambit
and then david sevilla is saying the
other knight comes out
so i'm assuming knight a3 and uh
we're getting a bunch of responses for
for king e7 which is
probably the best move on the board uh
obviously not
um but yeah dot spider in the chat here
is getting it correct the idea is going
for a d4 push expanding in the center
i know we had this idea of b4 calling a
delayed evans gambit but the problem is
if you play b4 it's defended by the pawn
and it's it's not a gambit
so d4 is the main idea here
this move can be considered a little
premature because
it blocks the natural square for the
knight this knight does want to go to c3
but we now block it
with this pawn so
it might be considered not good because
of that you're also creating a bit of a
hole
on d3 black can't take advantage of this
now but
let's just say they got like two free
moves and it would be protected this
knight to d3
could be annoying but that's that's in
the future
there is a plus side to this though in
that you are creating a second diagonal
for your queen
and in some of the lines we're going to
look at tonight we're going to be
looking at early queen a4
moves people are suggesting
bishop to b5 this may be an idea we see
later and we also get to mention in the
chat of the
rui lopez so some of the ideas here
may be very similar to a roy lopez or
a joko pianissimo where you get d3 and
you get this very slow push for d4
but i think in our main lines it's going
to be a little bit
more active with our pieces than the rui
and italian
okay so i have a couple people in the
chat benjamin fabian
looks like one suggesting moves for
black
and we're getting suggestions for bishop
to c5
and knight to f6 which are both very
logical moves
and we're going to be looking at knight
to f6 i want to cover bishop c5 though
because
i don't have that one in my notes but
after bishop to c5
i think white is just going to be much
better after
continuing with their plan of d4 and
okay if black ends up taking you take
back with your pawn the bishop has to
retreat
or i guess it can come to b4 with check
but
none of these moves cause white any
problem you now clear up the square for
your knight to go on c3
and i don't see what black has gained
out of this so
bishop c5 while it looks natural does
invite the straightforward move
pawn to d4
all right we should cover knight to
e7 so knight g to e7 is known as the
k-mac variation
and here i'm just going to suggest
bishop to b5
and this transposes to a rui lopez
cozio defense where the main move order
for that
is e4 e5 knight f3 knight c6 bishop
b5 and after the knight moves you play
c3
so that's gonna be my recommendation
just transpose to the roy lopez
i'm not going to be covering that
opening because it is a separate system
but i did want to mention knight g to e7
there is transposition there
now what if black tries this move d6
so d6 looks pretty good you're defending
the e pawn but there's a couple problems
with this
one you're blocking in your dark square
bishop so like i said
bishop to c5 does look attractive
and when you play d6 you block your
bishop in
now this is also trying to show that c3
is a little unnecessary
for white to play because after d6 it
looks like they're just strengthening
the center
but it's a little passive white can just
continue
pawn to d4 captures captures and again
we see with this trade on d4 it opens up
c3 for our knight and shouldn't cause
any problems
we just develop normally uh h3 is
stopping
bishop to g4 which pins the knight to
the queen
and loosens your grip on d4
but both sides just develop rather
naturally
and in this position white is
computers are giving it's almost plus
two but i'm just going to say white is
much better here
as the knights are developed to natural
squares you're ready to push
either pawn when necessary you just have
a very flexible position
with more space only white can be better
here
okay so
pawn to d6 doesn't look too great here
but we're going to get into our three
main moves here
and i'm going to cover i guess f5 first
f5 is one move and then the other moves
are knight to f6 and pawn to d5 but
we're going to cover f5
here which looks a little strange at
first but this is actually the move that
gave
the ponziani its more modern name
with the ponziani counter gambit
so here with f5 what is the point
well if white just takes
the very first idea you might have is
play
pawn to e4 and the idea of this is that
you are
trying to expand and because white has
conceded this control in the center but
this is not going to be the best plan
for black even knight d4
here this trade doesn't do
much for white instead white doesn't
actually go for this knight right away
they go queen
h5 first and now is something like g6
you're already going to be winning after
f takes g6 and you're threatening g7
checked by the queen and picking up the
rook
so taking this knight is a little bit of
a trap knight f6
is going to be better but white here
also doesn't have many problems
black's pawn was a little overextended
so if white takes
there are a couple other moves here and
white can also decline this
with pawn to d4 but you want to mention
after pawn takes
queen to f6 is going to be a very good
move i also want to mention expanding in
the center with d5
isn't going to be great because after
bishop to b5
black continues developing their pieces
rather naturally
while adding pressure to e5 and this
isn't going to be fun
just for an example you have to
reinforce e5
white just continues with d4 like
they've been wanting to all along
and i guess that black has to go e4 and
something like bishop g5 is playable
immediately
while your knight is attacked you do
attack their queen first
white is going to be fine after d5 so
you have to go queen f6 if you're
looking for maximum play
pawn to d4 and now after pawn to e4
you bring the knight to d2 just put
pressure on the pawn
this is going to be fine and after queen
takes f5 you can just go bishop e2
and i don't see how black is posing any
problems i think
white is just safe here but okay what
happens if white
doesn't take this this pawn here well
the other alternative is going pawn to
d4 again white just has this
this main theme they're going around
trying to get that d4 push in
and get a lot of space now here
normally black will take on e4 with the
pawn and white captures on e5 so
material
is equal and now we get either queen to
f6 or knight to f6
we'll take a look at knight f6 first
just putting a little bit of control on
e4 maybe the d5 square now bishop to g5
developing the bishop to a natural
square creating a pin
pawn to d6 kicking the knight trade of
knights
and knight to d2 putting pressure on e4
again
this position is going to be rather
equal black can play something like pawn
to d5 or they can try and attack
somewhere else with rook to b8 putting
pressure on the b
pawn so all these moves are fine bishop
e7 is going to be
fine here black may be down the pawn
but open lines for the bishops not going
to be struggling too much in development
should make for an interesting game
like i said if you're not going to play
knight f6 there's also
queen to f6 and here it gets a little
interesting
knight to g4 looks like a strange move
at first
you are attacking the queen but how
often do you get a knight on g4 on move
six
you just gotta be careful you don't hang
the knight anytime in the future after
black plays something like d5
but currently it is fine the queen is
protecting the knight
we get the queen to g6 saving the queen
from an attack
bishop to f4 developing we're developing
our queen side pieces
this knight does want to go to d2 so it
makes a lot of sense that we're
developing this bishop
right now before the night otherwise if
we develop the knight the bishop is
going to be stuck on c1 and we're going
to have problems developing it later
after bishop to f4 we do see d5 and we
see
this attack on the knight you
can play bishop e2 here and from what
i've seen this leads to rather unclear
positions
um queen f7 is one move that can be
played right away
attacking the bishop um
but i think the the recommendation i'm
gonna go for is knight to e3
and this may seem strange to a lot of
beginner players you know you're moving
this same piece
multiple times you moved it to f3 to e5
to g4 now you're moving it to e3 and
it's only move eight
half your moves have been knight moves
but i think retaining the knight keeping
it on the board in a central position
adding pressure to d5 uh should be fine
and here there's only one move for black
if black does not play this move white
already has
a very strong advantage plus one and a
half by stockfish 13
but the move they need to play is queen
to f7 this is to reinforce the d5 square
and this is also to add a little bit of
counter attack on this bishop
and now the bishop can drop back to g3
and now after
h5h4 i ended my analysis of this line
leaving it rather unclear position as
well
pretty balanced for both sides
black does have a lot of space white
does have a little bit of development
here that they can say is good for them
again i would say make for an
interesting game but theory doesn't need
to go
too deep as most players do not play f5
most players will now play knight to f6
or pawn to d5 so before we move on to
those moves i just want to make sure we
don't have any questions about f5
and the ponziani counter gambit
let's see looks like we don't have any
questions coming through
so we are going to move on here
i'm going to start covering d5 i think
look at d5 first this is the most
popular move and this is known as the
jainish counter attack
and this is black expanding before white
can putting pressure on the pawn
normally playing d5 really early
as black is not going to be too great
because of
pawn captures queen captures
and knight c3 but as you'll notice in
this position that's not possible
because the pawn is on c3
so playing d5 here can be considered
for black and like i said it is the most
popular move
after pawn to d5
what move should white play this is the
question white must
answer with his following move and it's
not too clear at first
if you just take the pawn black is going
to be happy they develop the queen get
it off the back rank
bishop g4 is going to come and then they
can castle queen side and there's no
problems for black
if you're not going to take
i guess what if you play d3 if you play
d3
black can capture you recapture
and you lose your right to castle which
isn't the best not going to lie
and then this pawn on e4 may be a little
tough
to defend i guess uh if you go knight to
d2 and f3 you have no problems but then
what is your knight doing on d2
so you don't want to give up your right
to castle you don't want to have to
start worrying about e4
we're getting a couple suggestions in
the chat we'll start with d4
which looks like it's possible but black
does gain a bit of an edge after pawn
takes on e4
knight takes on e5 and again for the
same reasons as d3
you don't want to lose your right to
castle because it will
delay your development of the rook so d4
also doesn't quite work
we have the suggestion of bishop to b5
but this is actually a mistake black can
get
an edge here where they are better after
d takes e4 because you're hanging this
pawn they might as well
take it and now knight takes e5
you take it back and they cannot
recapture because the knight is pinned
by
the bishop so we get queen g5
from black a very active move hitting
the knight hitting the pawn
and if you just move the knight back to
c4 to safety
well now you're hanging this bishop on
b5 so white
does need to be very careful queen to a4
here letting the knight hang
and the reason for this is that if they
take
well now white can take on c6 and what
was
giving up this knight is now resulting
in white getting a rook
so this is actually going to be just
fine
for for white but that's only if black
takes on e5
instead black should take on g2
and after queen takes g2 you have to
save your rook so rook f1
and this is not looking too great
already
your pawn on h2 is hanging your knight's
hanging out on e5 adding pressure you
have a lot of pressure on c6
but it's not going to be doing you too
much you're also
way behind in development on the queen
side let's see how black
can continue to keep their edge bishop
to d6 just attacking the knight
and now you can either take on c6 with
the knight or the bishop
but i think if you take on c6 with the
knight you run into this move
a6 which looks very strange for black to
play
because it looks like they have a
discovery
but the real question is where are you
going to put this knight
there's no great square if you try
knight to a5
they just take on b5 with the pawn and
you can take on b5 with your queen but
now after bishop to d7
you don't have a square where you can
save the knight
and the queen if you try queen to h5
protecting both
you run into knight f6 and this covers
the last square along
this rank which protects the knight
so unfortunately there is no good
discovery with
the knight so you have to do something
else
you might as well try d4 and try and
develop your queen side here but again
after knight f6
black is way ahead in development they
do have counter chances with
this attack on the bishop and
a lot of pressure with the queen in your
position
uh people are saying knight to a7
yeah what if you try knight to a7 well
you take on b5 again
and if you take with the queen you lose
your your uh sorry you don't lose the
knight right away bishop d7
first and i guess if you take on b7 you
can claim white is doing fine but after
rick to d8
white has nothing
if you have a follow-up here i'd love to
hear it but here black is just
up up too much in development looks like
they're up in material
not too great
we're getting knight to d4 if knight to
d4
again take on b5 because you're down a
piece from
white taking on c6 and okay
your only real try is taking on a8
but after knight to e7
the the pieces that black has are just
going to come flooding into your
position what do you try here
how are you going to develop your queen
side pieces
this is turning into risco place chat
what do you play in this position
all of white's pieces are just tied up
none of them are coordinating
maybe you tried d3
oh someone in chat said resign okay we
don't need to analyze this anymore
yeah after a6 black is just better
so if you take on c6 with the bishop
story is a little different
pawn takes and now you take on c6 with
the queen
but black is actually doing surprisingly
well
after king e7
and okay if you take on a8 with the
queen
bishop h3 is going to win the game
they're threatening mate
and knight f6 is going to be coming
there's no way to save your rook here
so after king e7 you can't take the rook
because of this
bishop h3 threat so pawn d4 creating a
flight square for your king
trying to open up something like bishop
g5
but it's not working because of the
queen and uh bishop h3
anyway here you have like
queen c4 if you want but
you're going to be losing an exchange
here so
this is why bishop to b5 is not
a great move
so we go back to move four what does
white actually play if none of these
moves are working
well we had it in the chat
queen to a4
we have a quick question in the chat has
the ponziani been played at the gm level
for sure this has been played at all
levels you don't see it
too much anymore at the grandmaster
level because some players might think
it's just too passive
for white for all the reasons we said
before you kind of block the natural
square of the knight
but this is this is for sure playable
and
you might see it more in blitz and rapid
games
probably not as much on classical
if you are looking for masters who do
play this opening
eric rosen has a lot of good content on
his channel
with the ponziani where you can see him
using some beginner tricks
but okay yeah queen a4 here and
this is threatening the e pawn actually
because you are still pinning the knight
and the difference between this and
bishop b5 is that uh
they they can't just take if they do
take well knight takes e5 you still have
this
and there is no a6
a6 does not exist because it's not
coming with tempo anymore
so that's one of the main differences
so how does black protect this pawn on
e5
there's a few different moves here we'll
start taking a look at them
like i said d takes e4 is not the best
here
just because knight takes and queen d5
is is fine
uh if you're not playing d takes e4
another try is queen d6 and this one i
was actually a bit of a fan of
because after queen d6 you're protecting
your pieces without compromising your
pawn structure
we get white playing d4 expanding in the
center
bishop d7 breaking this pin and now
queen b3 because you don't want to run
into knight d4
the queen b3 d takes e4 knight takes e5
takes takes takes and now
queen b7 and you get that pawn back from
before
and now rook d8 and so far um
pretty equal position you have knight d2
or bishop
to e3 as continuations for white and
computer says white has a small
advantage in these lines but
i think practically it's uh it's
anybody's game black does have the
development i think
uh in compensation for giving up the
queen side pawn
so that's an idea for black that i was a
fan of is a queen d6
but okay let's say you're not a fan of
giving up your queen side pawns like
that what else can you play
well you try bishop to d7 and this is
the caro variation
and this is probably black's best
scoring system
according to the databases i was looking
at the lee chess masters
the lead chess players and mega database
i guess there's a couple people in the
chat asking what if
white takes on a7 in the previous line
i might as well answer that
oh
come on leech us work with me here
queen d6 and we go through this line
uh there okay what if
white just takes well your queen's out
of the game here now bishop c5
first the queen's attacked so let's save
the queen and then
black finishes their development so at
the cost of the queenside pawns black is
fully developed and castle short is
coming
meanwhile your queen side isn't
developed at all and your king is stuck
in the center
why don't you take on d6 or sorry d5
you can take and after queen takes
you're fine you can still play d4
but i don't see i don't see the need to
trade off the pawns
like there's no no pressing reason why
you need to do it right away but you can
if you want
okay queen a4 back to the caro variation
bishop d7 like i said maybe black's best
scoring system
and i think it's because white has a few
moves
that are pretty much only moves i'm
pretty sure that's this
this variation here you take on d5
and after knight to d4 your queen is
being attacked
so you can't just take the knight you
have to go queen to d1
you're undeveloping the queen and now
knight takes f3
queen takes f3 and knight to f6
you can play bishop c4 protecting your
pawn again
developing getting ready to castle now
pawn to e4 from black it is supported by
the knight so you can't just take you
just go queen e2
bishop to d6 and if you play d4
this can lead in some unexplored
territory after castles
and h3 and rookie eight
um knight a3's possible continuation
uh or you can play pawn to d3 putting
pressure on the pawn right away
where after castles you can take knight
takes
and bishop to e3 closing up the file so
you don't run into any rookie eight
traps
rookie anyway to develop onto an open
file
knight d2 trades you can take with the
king
uh which is actually better than taking
with the queen which is a little odd if
you take with the queen
this runs into queen h4
and uh now you might have some problems
with the rook
trying to come in like rook can take on
e3 right away and if the queen takes
then rook to e8 and you're losing a
queen so
after queen takes d2 you run into some
very very
serious problems after queen h4 i should
also mention
this bishop on c4 is hanging so there's
no way to stop both of these threats
just go king to d2 and you maintain
a sense of equality
so a lot of traps white can fall for
in the coral
let's go back here the other two options
you have
are knight to f6 and pawn to f6 so we'll
cover knight to f6
and this is the leonhardt variation
where after takes on e5 again trying to
make use of this pin
you get bishop to d6 attacking the
knight
takes and then rather than take on c6
because
this runs into bishop d7 and your queen
has to go to a6
and your queen's kind of out of the game
and knight takes black just has
all the space in the world here rather
than take and allow that
you play pawn to d3 supporting your pawn
if they do take you're fine to take back
with your pawn
uh let's see but black will normally
play castles
followed by a bishop e2 and rookie eight
and here uh theory is saying
that uh if white ever takes this pawn
black's just going to be better and this
is mainly because of the move bishop to
d7
so don't get too tempted don't take this
pawn just continue
with normal development something like
bishop g5
is completely fine here
okay um let's
go back that's the kind of the gist of
the lionheart variation
but now we're going to get into f6 this
might freak some of you guys out
long time viewers who remember ben
feingold's lectures are probably
screaming right now
but f6 is the main move here
this is known as the steinitz variation
and
maybe the best move for black now the
argument against this
is that you're blocking the development
of the knight
what do you do well you just have to
deal with it right now
white is going to pile up pressure on c6
and now you get knight to e7
protecting the knight with the other
knight that way if bishop captures
you can maintain your pawn structure
takes on d5 queen takes d5 you can't
really take with the knight because this
defeats
the purpose of knight e7 so
queen takes and again you don't have
knight c3 here that's why this is okay
for black
instead white continues with d4
if you try to castle right away bishop
d7 is going to give up
a lot of the pressure white has on the
position and black may actually be
coming out ahead here
so you go d4 create a bit of tension in
the center
bishop to d7 to relieve the pressure on
the a4 to e8 diagonal
and now bishop to e3
here white has not had the most
favorable score
and it's actually i believe this
specific line
which is why most players don't play the
ponziani anymore
is because black's pawn structure is
very solid
all of the pieces are developed black is
getting ready to castle
not queen side i don't think because
there is pressure here but
this knight developing to f5 is possible
um but yeah here there's just a lot of
good moves i think even just rook d8
right here
but i like i like knight f5 just keeping
up
pressure so because of this variation
white can face a lot of trouble
and that covers i think most of the d5
moves
i guess the best response is from white
just know after d5 you go queen a4 and
pin the knight
we'll get into the last alternative here
knight f6 but i do want to take another
moment
make sure we don't have any questions
after pawn to d5
give it another 10 seconds get those
questions in
all right i'm not seeing any questions
we're moving right along
knight f6 this is the second most
popular move
and honestly a really nice try
let's see let me keep up in my notes
here
all right so after knight f6 what do you
guys think white's move is here
i don't think it should be uh too crazy
fetisheen is saying play d3 if they play
d5 we already covered that they take on
e4 and you lose your right to castle
but okay if you guessed d4 you got it
right
i mean this is this is white's plan all
along play d4 when it's safe
so this just keeps in line with c3 if
you get your lines mixed up
and you play queen a4 you're still going
to be fine here
just black is able to play d6 and now
you no longer have stuff like knight e5
to put pressure on c6 so something like
bishop b5 might be the way you continue
bishop d7 and it's all because this e5
pawn is protected you're not going to
have those tactics
as before so
d4 and now they take on e4
they can also take this pawn on d4
and this this capture here taking on d4
is another possible transposition into
the goring gambit
and it's a bit more double-edged than
the main line we're going to be looking
at
but white is going to play e5 and after
knight to d5
c takes bishop to b4 and you block with
the bishop
and after the trade you come out you
come out fine white does have space
black has a bit better development with
their knights
they can also play knight e4 instead of
knight d5
and this only changes slightly that
if the knight can also control d2 you
want to block with the knight you don't
want
to play bishop d2 and have them trade
the knight for the bishop this would not
be a favorable exchange
as your knight results in a pin and
knights are a little bit weaker than
bishops or bishops are slightly stronger
in general so
e takes d4 is possible
but the main line we're going to be
looking at is knight takes e4
and the general rule for the ponziano is
that whichever
pawn they capture you push the other and
this is to disrupt black's development
so here after pawn d5 this knight must
move
and when this knight moves it's going to
give up control of e5
so where does black move
that's the new question well one can
argue that black
doesn't need to move the knight at all
and can play bishop to c5
the direct idea is that there is this
double threat on f2 so
if white takes on c3 it makes sense that
black would capture on f2 with the
bishop for the trek and forces the king
to e2
now the bishop goes back to b6 and the
idea is you're clearing the square
for the knight to go to f2
and now here the only move for white is
queen to d5
a very awkward looking move but you are
forking black's position here
and then knight to f2 attacking the rook
here you can save the rook and after
castle's short
take on b7 black captures
and now you you have to capture on b7
otherwise
your position is going to fall apart but
you take on b7
and the idea of giving up this piece is
so they can go queen f6
and this position can be very scary for
white if you don't know what you're
doing
here we get knight to a3 this is really
the only way to develop this knight
anymore
you can also go to d2 but you do block
your bishop
and here with you being so far behind in
development i don't really recommend it
you just go go knight a3 leave this
diagonal
open for your bishop you get pawn to e4
attacking the knight and you get knight
to c4
you can't go knight to uh d4 because
knight
g4 is going to be a huge threat um just
queen to f2
so you have to leave the knight here you
play knight c4
and rook to b8 is possible to play first
again if white ever moves the knight
well okay first you lose the queen but
again
knight g4 is also winning here
so you have to leave knight on f3 rook a
to b8
queen d5 is the only real safe square if
they go to a6
then takes on f3 if you take with the
pawn
then rook to e8 so
queen to d5 takes on f3
g takes and now rook f to e8 the
position's slightly different you do
have king to d2
and after knight to e4 trek this is
trying to open up the position so that
after you take
bishop takes g1 and this is kind of kind
of the point of moving the knight
you get the rook in the end bishop to d3
holding on to e4 and now we get
um really any move by black here
um that's right not any move but like c6
or queen f2
but probably queen f2 is what you'll see
black being very aggressive
you just have to go king d1 you can't
block with the bishop
because when you block just queen to g2
they're adding more pressure
to your position and it's really hard to
save this pawn now
so queen f2 is probably a good
good move there so bishop c5 sacrificing
a piece
if you see your opponent play this this
is a real line they are not just giving
up the knight on c6
for nothing another move that this
knight on c6
can i guess black can play is this
knight on c6 to
b8 and just retreat the knight
and here you can take on e5 this was the
point of playing pawn to d5
and now queen e7 attacking the knight so
here
you get queen to d4 protecting
and pawn to d6 attacking the knight yet
again you have a couple options here but
i'm going to recommend
just bishop to b5 check they block
with the bishop when they block with the
bishop you can capture
with your own when they take back with
knight now you trade knights
knight f6 is a very uh kind of creative
move just making sure
white is i mean white can lose their
right to castle bishop b3 just
remedies this but then you take on d7
with the queen here you can't do that
before because this knight on
e4 will hang
and here white has been known to be
slightly better
instead of knight to b8 the main move
here
is knight to e7 with the point that
you're putting pressure on d5
and here we get knight takes e5
again the entire point of playing pawn
d5 so you can recapture the pawn on e5
and here the most
played move in this position is actually
a really bad move
the most played move here is d6 but this
is a trap after d6 which looks very
logical you want to kick the night out
of your position
white already has a one game
bishop to b5 check and
the point is that uh black is going to
lose a queen
if they block with the bishop you take
with your own bishop the king is
smothered so you have to take with the
queen
and now white is up a queen no further
analysis needed there
if you try blocking with the pawn you
capture on c6 with your own pawn
if they capture back now you run into
knight takes c6
and if they take on c6 with the knight
you capture with the bishop
and now after bishop d7 you you don't go
for this rook on a8 you actually go for
the knight on e4
it's better to win a piece than to win
an exchange
uh and here they can try queen to e7
winning the bishop back
but you just castle and if they try to
get the bishop
they run into rookie one and they're
losing the queen here as well
so the main move pawn to d6
just not good for not
good for black at all i also want to
cover
knight to f7 because we did get this
recommendation
last week when we covered this line but
after king takes f7
white really has no follow-up if you try
queen f3 they just block with the
knights
on f6 and white is down a clean piece
so just wanted to make sure we mentioned
that as well
but okay after knight takes e5 what
should black play
they can't play d6 because it fails to
the bishop check
the safest way for them to continue is
knight to g6
offering a trade of knights and if they
do trade black is going to be happy
they just take with the h pawn take with
the h
pawn and now your rook is on an open
file without developing
your knight is okay to jump back but
okay let's say white tries queen e2
which is the main move
trying to pin the knight here queen e7
is forced
you can't go f5 because of f3
so you run into queen e7 and now bishop
to f4 just develops you're hitting this
pawn on c7
you get pawn to d6 protecting this pawn
on c7
and knight to a3 you're going to bring
your knight into the center and develop
this way
and one of the moves here that black has
that has been played is also rook h5
but after like rook h5 castle and queen
side rook f5 hitting the bishop
just bishop g3
actually sorry not bishop g3 i have my
notes mixed around bishop g3 is the
wrong move to play
very natural but fails to knight f2
if you end up taking on f2 queen e2
bishop e2
and rook f2 so rather than bishop g3
which is the natural move you want to
play queen
e3 protecting the bishop so my apologies
you should play queen e3 here um
and i guess how does black continue
um you don't want to go bishop d7
because g4 will kind of trap the rook
um not bishop g5 here
probably just bishop g2 instead
is the continuation so you'll probably
see
knight to f6 offering a trade of queens
this might be a way to continue for
black
g5 alo trevi if you're putting g5 i ask
that you mention where it's hard to to
analyze if you just give a move
it is a legal move but i don't know what
the point is
yes g5 by black because black's the only
one who can play it but where
after what move
g5 here g5 here
now you can go um bishop g3
this is fine i don't see the point
you put a lot of question marks like g5
with some stellar move
what do you do after this
this does not uh work out the same way
after knight to f2
bishop f2 tactics my friend
the queen is now protected by the bishop
so there's no queen trade
and if you take on f2 you take on f2
with the queen
you're losing a piece here
the difference is where the queen is and
if black can get a queen trade
it's all good
but okay we'll go back
um that's if white ends up taking the
knight
um you don't need to take the knight
here you can just play
queen takes d4 so
queen or sorry not takes just queen 2d
for protecting the knight this was kind
of the same idea we had with um
one of the other variations where the
knight was hanging by the queen
so queen f6 putting more pressure on the
knight
and the the trade-off here is that white
is going to get this knight on e4
and give up the knight on e5 and now we
might see a queen trade
and after this queen trade i think that
white's doing fairly well they do have
space and it's hard to see how black is
going to take advantage of this right
away
and white can continue developing with
tempo mainly with bishop f4 hitting the
knight
now if the knight goes back to g6 you
hang this pawn on c7 and white has a
winning end game
so you have to play d6 and once you play
d6
your bishop is no longer controlling a3
so white goes knight to a3
and we'll develop the knight through c2
and
most likely on d4 we get bishop to e7
knight to c4 is also possible the idea
is that if
knight takes you take with the bishop
and all your pieces are developed you're
going to castle next move
or again you have moves like knight to
c2
if you want to develop the knight to the
center but
here at this point i think i can safely
say we are out of the opening and in the
end game
some people are probably going to say
it's just a middle game but
quasi in the game uh and this is where
i'm going to leave
off the analysis here in this position
i think it's almost completely equal for
both sides
but someone's saying knight b5
in this position and they're saying it's
better
[Music]
how exactly is it better after king d8
so king d8 i just protect
with the queens off the board it's
actually not so important
if black can castle or not
at least here with development for both
sides in previous lines where
you were losing the queens and the right
to castle that was different because you
didn't have development
but here both sides do and i don't see
how much better white is because they
want knight b5
i guess now you get knight d4 i guess
this can be considered better because
it's a more forcing way to develop the
knights but
other than that i don't see
don't see the point i mean this does
allow rookie 8 right away
but isn't interesting
the rook will have a long time to
develop i just developed the rook
and the rook on the queen side the the
time for
the rook on the queen side to develop
doesn't change
but i think this is uh still a fun it's
a fine move to play
but i i won't say this is any margin
better
but all right so we're gonna open up the
last uh 10 minutes here
four questions uh no need to apologize
in the chat
they're definitely interesting ideas
but uh yeah if you have any questions on
any of the lines if you've thought of
something after we moved on
now is your time to go back and ask your
questions
in this position white may be better
it's kind of scary from black's
point of view it might be scary from
black's point of view because white does
have the space
what if bishop d6 instead of pawn d6
good question
so bishop d6 and the point is that um
i guess you're still you're still
defending the knight you're getting
ready to castle
uh i guess the main problem here
is knight f3 knight f3 is a threat
we're at bishop f4 i'm blocking with the
bishop
on d6 or sorry defender
ben needs to get the board back
our board is missing
i'm just going to go to a full screen
board and then
concur and then we're on we're back
we're back so i here
okay bishop f4 blocking with the bishop
or defending the knight
uh and the threat is that if white does
nothing
like a 4 knight f3
and white is going to kind of be forced
to uh to ruin the pawn structure
and lose a bishop or their king is going
to be
kind of exposed i guess the pawn
structure is getting ruined anyway right
so you can't obviously don't play a4 but
the remedy to this
is knight to d2 that way if knight goes
to f3
you take on f3 you still lose your
bishop pair
but you're left with your good bishop on
the light squares
with these pawns on the dark squares and
your knights developed
so that's kind of what will happen if
you play bishop d6
maybe you might prefer this as black
i think i like it more when you have
more pieces on the board because you can
generate more chances that way
but hopefully that will uh hopefully
that will
answer your question then i wish i could
pronounce your name
but it looks like it's written in
russian so
mr russian person or mrs russian person
there you go that's what happens if you
play bishop d6
all right do we have any other questions
about the ponziani
welcome you're welcome
let's see i will i guess i'll give our
brief
summary here
e4 e5 knight f3 knight c6 pawn c3 this
is the ponziani opening
and the three main variations are f5 the
ponziani counter gambit
where white can play d4 or takes but
d4 is more popular um
and black has to play queen f6 otherwise
white
is going to get a bit of a lead and you
play knight g4
the the strange strange-looking move and
bring the knight back to e3
if you're not playing the ponziani
counter gambit there's d5
where white plays queen a4 if you can
create a pin here
you do it and then this works because
the knight can capture on e5 and add
more pressure
and f6 is probably the best response
strange looking
makes ben feingold have a heart attack
before bed every night
but here we go f6
you increase the pressure on the pin
and develop as such
and then there is knight to f6
which is uh where you go
pawn to d4 right away knight takes e4
and pawn d5 you capture the pawn on e5
you get your pawn back
and then trade off knights in the center
and you will result
in this type of end game
all right um if black is greedy taking
on
e4 with the knight
let me see i'm just double checking here
uh here after knight of six and they
take right away this is our main line
yeah so we've already covered this
but all right if there are no more
questions we will wrap up the lecture
here
and we are going to move into uh the
second to last
of our series the winners circle where
we're going to be covering the last
few rounds of vasilis misloves 1953
zurich candidates run so i'll hope to
see you there
you